so inflation's come down from 10.4 to
10.1 good news yes but no because we
were hoping it would come down a little
bit more aggressively than that we were
hoping that this would be the month that
inflation came in at below 10 but it's
proving a little bit more stubborn than
we'd like
um however nevertheless it has come down
pretty much consistently since October
except a surprise blip last month since
October when it peaked at 11.1 percent
that was a 41 year high now these
figures have just dropped so we don't
know exactly what what the drivers of it
are but what we do know is that energy
prices
have been coming down over the last few
months wholesale gas prices are now
lower than they were before the war in
Ukraine began in February last year
and then of course there's food which
has been rise it has been rising at a
staggering pace around 18 last month I
mean even even with inflation polling by
0.1 percent you I mean we could be in a
situation where food is food has
continuing to rise we're still Rising
Energy prices might be in fact food
prices are rising just head in my ear
there are food 19.1 what's that terms of
inflation right that's higher than last
amazing yeah higher than last year and
of course when we talk about inflation
inflation may be coming down but that
doesn't mean prices are coming down it
just means they're Rising a little bit
less slowly so it's not going to provide
a huge amount of relief um at the
supermarket that being said food and
energy prices can be pretty volatile so
when policy makers are thinking about
whether they can cut interest rates
they'll be looking at core inflation
this strips out things like uh food and
energy and they'll want to see this that
that's cooling because it's only when
that starts to cool that they can be
confident that there's not domestically
generated inflation in the economy and
we had figures out yesterday showing
that wages still Rising pretty robustly
in the UK and when wages rise that can
force businesses to put their prices up
even higher so all of this has raised
the prospect that the bank of England
may have to raise interest rates when it
meets later in the week and it won't
want to take its eye off the ball of
wage wage increases just Just One Last
point do we think then that when Rishi
sumac promised to half inflation that we
are going to get to that point in the
basis of what we're seeing right now yes
because I don't think this changes
fundamentally economists forecasts for
the year ahead because some of those
increases in food prices as we said
should start to drop out off the
calculation soon enough and it should
level out over the course of the year
but one thing that these figures do show
is that Economist forecasts can be
proven wrong they thought inflation was
going to fall to 9.8 today and it didn't